we wanted to present one of our guests
today in
the more traditional lecture format
and those who have heard our next guest
either on one of his many tv appearances
or
the lectures that c-span has broadcast
over the years
will know what a treat we're in for
and that guest is historian h.w brans
author of the just released book
which you see
peeking out over my shoulder
the zealot and the emancipator
john brown
abraham lincoln and the struggle for
american freedom
anyone who's observed the controversies
this past year over
lincoln statues
that celebrate his role as an
emancipator or
seen the new
and current tv series the good lord byrd
which dramatizes john brown
as a
zealous
or freedom fighter
knows that this is a piece of history
that could not be more current and
relevant and professor brans has
responded as he always does with a book
of great insight and high drama
work of deep research sound analysis and
good old-fashioned narrative drama and
momentum and few people do it better
so now to uh use a quote from publishers
weekly
let me bring on the insightful and
entertaining jack blanton chairman
in the in history at the university of
texas at austin h.w bryant so bill over
to you
thank you harold for that very kind
introduction and thank you to the
lincoln forum for the opportunity to
address you
and i'm especially drawn to the forum
aspect of this because i hope we can
have a lively conversation toward the
end of my panel
so
i'm going to explain why i wrote a book
about john brown and abraham lincoln and
part of the short answer is
that i couldn't write a book simply
about abraham lincoln it's
well known to this audience there are
lots and lots of books about abraham
lincoln
so i needed to bring somebody else into
the story and this actually reflects
some of my experience in writing
biographies i've written several
biographies and i discover in writing
biography that try as one might the
biographer cannot help
but give the impression that his or her
subject is the center of the universe
and as important as any individual might
be that individual is not at the center
of the universe
so i wanted to
try something that would decenter
somebody like lincoln and look at
lincoln from another perspective but
also pair lincoln with somebody else
and john brown was a mere contemporary
of lincoln but he was also very useful
to me
because
i wanted to pose a question
to my readers
a question that i posed to my students i
teach at the university of texas and i
make a point of teaching introductory
classes
to students who are 18 19 years old who
are on the cusp of becoming
citizens of this republic
and it's a question that well i thought
of it as a timeless question and it is
certainly important for citizenship but
it goes beyond this and the the heart of
the question is what does a good person
do in the face of evil
now
you can interpret that any way you want
the way i chose to interpret is well in
the context of the mid
century
what does
a person convinced of
the wrongness the evil the bad policy
aspects of slavery
what does that person do about it what
do you do
if you're convinced as john brown was as
abraham lincoln was if you're convinced
that slavery is wrong
john brown would have emphasized the
evil aspect of it the sinful aspect of
it but abraham lincoln conceded nothing
to john brown in his conviction that
slavery was wrong lincoln would indeed
bring in other aspects as well as bad
policy it's bad for white people as well
as
black people it's bad for it threatens
the future of democracy
it is wrong so
the question is though what do you do
about it and so i wanted to look at two
people who agreed that this thing was
wrong but took diametrically opposite
views about what to do about it
and so i look at john brown i look at
abraham lincoln
primarily through the lens of
their attitudes towards slavery and more
importantly their actions towards
slavery
and
they were both born in the first decade
of the 19th century and this is
important for this story because
american attitudes towards slavery were
changing during this time
i think it's fair to say
that at the time of the founding of this
republic
in 1776
nearly everybody who thought about the
question at all
thought that slavery was at best a
necessary evil
almost nobody at that time thought
slavery was a good thing other things
being equal they thought it fell in the
category of necessary evils like like
war i mean almost nobody thinks that war
is a good thing
but on the other hand there aren't very
many people who say that countries like
the united states should forswear war
under any circumstances so it falls in
the category of
we don't like it but sometimes in this
world you get wrapped up in this stuff
and attitudes towards slavery in the
1770s 80s 90s fell largely in this
category and so you would find people
like thomas jefferson george washington
who were slave holders
but also opposed to slavery in principle
and
thomas jefferson his whole life tried to
figure out how to end slavery because he
concluded that slavery is not good for
the republic slavery is this bad thing
it corrupts slave owners it corrupts
their children it corrupts democracy and
it might very well bring down america's
experiment in self-government
now an obvious sort of response to this
and and sort of the 21st century obvious
response to thomas jefferson is well
okay you think slavery is wrong why
don't you start by freeing your slaves
well i would pose the question to people
today comparably if you think
war is wrong why don't you simply not
wage war
because today people can't figure out
sort of how to deal with their world
most people without war there are some
committed pacifists out there but
they're a very small minority anyway
oh i should add and this is actually
crucial to the position that jefferson
took that washington took
they thought that slavery was on its way
out that it was a dying institution they
lived long enough to see that slavery
was being ended in the northern states
so that by 1800 by the beginning of the
19th century the northern states had all
consigned slavery to the past or it was
on its way out
and this
not because northerners were
grabbed by a fit of morality but because
their economies had evolved in a way
that rendered slavery unprofitable
unnecessary and so if you have this sort
of formula of a necessary evil and it's
no longer necessary then you can focus
on evenly scale okay let's get rid of
slavery and jefferson thought washington
thought that slavery was falling in the
same category in the south what they do
and they they noticed that slavery for
example unknown i'm sorry that tobacco
cultivation which in the south was done
by slaves and actually was done by
slaves in connecticut as well
um it was exhausting the soil and they
they figured that okay it's time has
come and gone and
soon enough southern states will come to
the conclusion that the northern states
are already coming to that slavery is
on its way out and the southern states
will choose to end slavery what
jefferson didn't see or washington
didn't see most of people at the time
didn't see was first of all the
invention of the cotton gin and secondly
the and the consequent enormous growth
in the cultivation of cotton which made
slavery really profitable in the states
where
new land could be found and so slavery
spread and it had this um sort of
backflow
influence on the profitability of
slavery in places like virginia so
slavery was never particularly
profitable in
virginia and other states of the eastern
seaboard i'll leave the side maybe south
carolina but in virginia which was kind
of the key to all this slavery wasn't
particularly profitable on its own
merits in virginia by the beginning of
the 19th century what made slavery
profitable in places like virginia was
and this is going to seem paradoxical
maybe was the ending of the
international slave trade to the united
states the cutting off of imports
because that raised the value of slaves
if you put a tariff on things or if you
block imports and things then the value
goes up
and then virginia could export slaves to
the new gulf coast states into places
like texas and so this made slavery
really profitable and what this meant
was that for people like well by the
time jefferson died he realized uh oh i
was wrong about this and a new
generation of statesmen of political
leaders came along henry clay henry clay
was
uh
in many ways thomas jefferson's heir he
was a kentuckian he was a slave holder
and he was also
against slavery so and now back to that
question why didn't jefferson just
emancipate his slaves why didn't clay
emancipate his slaves clay did
emancipate his slaves after his death
but why not in his life and the answer
they would have given was that if thomas
jefferson freed his slaves if henry clay
freed his slaves
that would have an effect on the lives
of those slaves which is no small thing
but it would lose them any political
leverage they have over persuading their
fellow slaveholders in virginia or in
kentucky to free their slaves because
they would simply have become another
abolitionist but for a slave holder to
argue against his own material interest
and say let's end slavery that would
give that person much more credibility
anyway this didn't work and so by the
1830s by the 1830s it became clear that
slavery was in it for the long haul and
it caused people who were opposed to
slavery to fall into a couple of
different camps and in one camp was john
brennan
john brown was born
in new england but his family moved to
ohio when he was a young boy and he grew
up in the southern part of ohio near
kentucky slave state kentucky where
he had contact with slaves on a regular
basis people who owned slaves in
kentucky would bring them across the
border and people in ohio would go into
kentucky and let's see slaves so john
brown was sort of used to this as a kid
except he didn't understand quite what
it meant
until one day and he recalled this in
his later life
he was about nine eight or nine years
old and he remembered he was playing one
day with a playmate a boy who happened
to be a black boy
and john brad didn't realize it or
didn't sink in that this boy was a slave
until
until after they've been playing
together essentially as equals
then this white man came along and
started yelling at the boy and beating
over the head you know and just abusing
him
and
it dawned on john brown well wait a
minute okay so this black boy is in a
very different position than i am
because nobody could ever do that to me
and get away with it but obviously this
guy can do it to this black boy and so
at that point john brown realized
there's something really wrong with
slavery
but he didn't know what to do about it
and this again is my fundamental
question once you agree that slavery is
wrong what do you do about it john brown
didn't know what to do about slavery for
many years
he was
kind of mildly opposed to slavery as
many people were mildly opposed to
slavery but it wasn't until it wasn't
until the 1830s that
his opposition to slavery sort of
galvanized in the form that made him the
john brown who became known to history
now i have to say something here and
that is that john brown was not a
successful man he was not successful as
a farmer he was not successful as a
sheep herder or a cow herder he was not
successful in various business ventures
he tried
and it's a hypothetical but i think it's
probably fairly reasonable to say that
if john brown had been more successful
at something else he might never have
become the person that history knows and
as this is not unusual people often find
their calling sort of by the process of
elimination
but the critical moment in john brown's
evolution on slavery
came in 1837
when elijah lovejoy an abolitionist
editor was murdered by
a pro-slavery mob
and
1837 this is several years into the
birth of the full-throated abolitionist
movement in the north
there had been i'll call them
emancipationists
earlier quakers for example in the 18th
century and there had been people who
thought slavery is wrong has moved to
end it
but many of them had been gradualists so
for example when new york ended slavery
it did so in a phased manner and this
was very common and one of the reasons
it was common was that the people who
were emancipating the slaves had to get
around a fundamental problem and a
source of opposition to the ending of
slavery and that is slaves slaves were a
valuable form of property and if some
person had just invested a thousand
dollars in a slave and then was told the
next day oh we're freeing your slave
well that person would have
an economic complaint leave aside the
moral question but there would be an
economic incentive to say wait wait wait
we're not going to do that
so typically the emancipation in the
north took this phase form so after 10
years
any
after 10 years then
slave children who become adults okay
they will be freed
and anybody born after a certain time
will be free so we would give people
time to factor this in
the abolitionists took a different view
the abolitionist took the attitude that
slavery is so wrong so evil that it must
be ended immediately
and essentially at all costs now what
did all costs really mean
for many abolitionists william lloyd
garrison was probably the best known of
the publishing abolitionists
it meant that
opposition to slavery overrode
an attachment to the idea of the rule of
law william lloyd garrison famously
burned a copy of the constitution saying
this is what i think of the constitution
because the constitution allows slavery
so
abolitionists the real hardcore
abolitionists took the i took the
attitude that
opposition to slavery justifies almost
anything
but few of them were willing to go as
far as john brown and john brown himself
was unwilling to go as far as he did
until events of the 1850s shocked him
into action the 1850s was the decade
when is the decade of truth for
the american republic and for dealing
with the dual
problems that persisted since the
writing of the constitution
so
the constitution the constitution was
not revered in those days the way it
often is today in part because
people were still living who knew the
people who wrote the thing and it's hard
to think of your next door neighbor as a
demigod or something like that you know
okay they're politicians and they're
trying to solve the problems that they
can solve but there were two fundamental
flaws with the constitution and one was
how do you square
the existence of states within a federal
republic where does the balance lie
between the authority of the states and
the authority of the national government
and this one was deliberately fudged by
the framers of the constitution
because they knew if they said okay if
they wrote it down very clearly
the federal government always takes
precedence over the states
then the small states would have said
forget it we're not going to join this
because under the existing government
the irs confederation the states were
sovereign and all the states were equal
and in this new government the big
states would be more equal than the
small states by virtue of their larger
representation in the house of
representatives and in the electoral
college
so
if they had said quite clearly
the federal government is always supreme
they wouldn't have gotten anybody to
sign if they had said oh the states are
always supreme when push comes to shove
then it would have been no improvement
over the articles confederation so they
left this one deliberately vague and the
people who wrote the constitution
understood that
we didn't answer this question we will
just hope that
uh when the question has to be answered
there will be people smarter than us or
they'll be in a position to answer the
question in a way we can't at the moment
so
there's that problem and the other
problem is the existence of slavery in a
republic a republic is a political
system based on the principle that
people are equal thomas jefferson of
course has stated very clearly all men
are created equal
exactly who he was talking about and
what he was trying to say then has been
the source of debate ever since but it
was very clear in the context of a
republic one person one vote and all
this again who votes and so on that's
it's an issue that we evolve over time
but when you had a class of people
slaves who were so clearly unequal to
everybody else then you were asking for
trouble and again
the framers of the constitution knew
they were asking for trouble except that
for the reasons that i explained earlier
in 1787 they pretty much all thought
that slavery was going to die of its own
weight within 10 or 15 years they also
knew that if they spelled it out exactly
in the constitution you know if they
couldn't come up with a fudge that the
three-fifths compromise and all that
stuff then the the large slave-holding
states in the south simply wouldn't sign
and they wouldn't get this constitution
so in that case as in the case of the
federal government versus the state
governments they kicked the can down the
road and basically they took the
position articulated by benjamin
franklin to close the constitution
convention this constitution isn't
perfect but it's the best we can do
under the circumstances so let's take it
out there and let the next generation
the generation after that fix it
okay well there's this iou and these
pair of ious and they're hanging over
the country until the 1850s and it
becomes pretty clear that the debts are
going to have to be paid the
flaws are going to have to be remedied
by one means or another so kicking off
the decade was the compromise of 1850
which outraged elements on both sides of
mason-dixon line the south was really
upset that california was admitted as a
free state this
delivered the senate
into the hands of the free state they
i'm not going to call them exactly the
anti-slavery forces because not
everybody in the north was particularly
opposed to slavery and um us only a
small minority made it a overriding
issue but the north was a different
region and people did think regionally
in those days even more than they do
today
much more than they do today so the
south lost control of the senate it lost
even its veto in the senate because
there were more
northern states now more northern
senators than there were southern
centers but the north was outraged
because as the quid pro quo that the
south insisted on it was a new fugitive
slave act and it was a new fugitive save
act that made more necessary than ever
the work of people like harriet tubman
of whom we just heard
um because it before 1850 before the the
new fugitive state act it was often
sufficient if someone
fled slavery it was often sufficient
simply to cross the ohio river and get
into a free state like ohio and then you
could kind of melt into the population
the way frederick douglass melted into
the population of
philadelphia when he got away from
maryland
and but the fugitive the fugitive slave
act meant that you had to get all the
way to canada because the fugitive slave
act required northern sheriffs judges
even private individuals to assist in
the return of fugitive slaves and for
northerners who opposed to slavery to
say i have to help in the capture of
fugitive slaves this was a clear
violation of their conscience they were
outraged so
north and south both thought the
compromise of i should say there were
large elements in the north and south
that
loathe part of the compromise of 1850
and they began to point fingers more
seriously than ever at the other side
the kansas nebraska act of 1854 the work
primarily of illinois center stephen
douglas
this is one that blew the tops off the
heads of many northerners and especially
people opposed to slavery
the the crux of the kansas nebraska act
was to repeal that portion of the
missouri compromise of 1820
that had barred slavery from the
northern part of the louisiana purchase
that was 1820 this is 1854. it fell in
the category of what the jurists call
settled law it's been around for a long
time and northerners those people who
are opposed to slavery
they presume that that was the permanent
deal and their hope was still that if
the growth of slavery could be contained
then slavery eventually would fall under
its own weight
but
the kansas nebraska act said sorry we're
taking that lid off of slavery
and this was compounded three years
later when the dred scott case the
greatest scout decision said that
the missouri compromise that part of the
missouri compromise had been
unconstitutional from the beginning
because after the the kansas nebraska
act it was possible for people like
abraham lincoln who returned to politics
in illinois largely because of the
kansas-nebraska act it was possible for
him to say okay
congress made a bad decision in
repealing that ban on
slavery in the northern part of the
western territories
but if congress made a bad decision in
1854 it could make a good decision in
1856 and restore the ban the dred scott
decision said no congress cannot do that
the basis of the dred scott decision was
that slaves were property
and just as congress could not tell
a guy in missouri who wanted to take his
horse into kansas
um because property's property and you
can take your property across state
lines it couldn't tell a slave holder in
missouri that he couldn't take his slave
across the lines into kansas territory
what the kansas-nebraska act did on the
ground though
was to give both sides
pro-slavery anti-slavery an opportunity
to basically
flex their muscles
ahead of some sort of military conflict
because
the principle on which
kansas kansas territory was open to
settlement was what stephen douglas
called popular sovereignty and it sounds
innocuous on its face it's as democratic
as can be
uh settlers from any states in the union
can go into kansas territory and they
can take their property with them or
that property happens to be mules and
horses or slaves so they can come in
from the slave south they can come in
from the free north and when kansas
territory gets a population large enough
to warrant a constitution a state
constitution those people then president
in kansas territory will write a
constitution and at that point they'll
decide
for slavery or against slavery it's up
to them this is a democracy people ought
to get the government they want
who could argue with that well
in fact lincoln argued with it because
it overturned this basic principle been
around for a long time
john brown decided to argue it in
another way so
once the doors of kansas were open
then
settlers
came into kansas territory from the
south and they had an advantage because
kansas assuming kansas right next to
missouri missouri was a slave state and
they could pour across the line
but settlers came in from north from the
north john brown at this point was
living in upstate new york and so he
decides to go to kansas territory
actually a couple of his before his
adult sons precede him into kansas
because they've decided here is the time
to make our stand for freedom and
they're going to be part of that
migration from the north to get to
kansas and to settle the territory in
greater numbers than the settlers from
the south so when the time comes to
write the constitution freedom will win
and they write letters home to dad and
say dear father come to kansas this is
where the battle over slavery is being
fought so john brown says sure i'm
coming
and john brown sort of
found his calling in kansas because he
discovered
that
he had a kind of personal magnetism
people were drawn to john brown
and they were drawn to john brown in a
way that some of them didn't
particularly like
they were drawn to commit actions of
violence that they almost certainly
never would have done
without the leadership of john brown so
what did john brown do first of all he
watched when the pro-slavery immigrants
to kansas
they
stuffed ballot boxes and they elected a
bogus territorial legislature this
annoyed him
but then bans of pro-slavery militias
descended on the free state
that is the northern colonized community
of lawrence kansas and they basically
destroyed the town and the people living
in lawrence didn't put up a fight and
john brown was incensed at this he could
hardly decide whether he was more
incensed at the pro-slavery militia the
so-called the border ruffians from
missouri or
more incensed at the
anti-slavery forces in lawrence for not
standing up for themselves so john brown
decided to send a message
to the pro-slavery assad
one dark night he led a small band of
his followers including a couple of his
sons
and they descended on a small hamlet on
the banks of potawatomi creek in kansas
territory and they dragged five
pro-slavery settlers men from their beds
and brutally murdered them hacked them
to death with broadswords and left the
corpses in pieces lying on the ground
the purpose of this was to send a
message
to others who are thinking about coming
to kansas for similar purposes that this
could happen to them
now i'm always loath
to import to the past
terminology from the present i'll just
say
that if this happened today
without blinking an eye people would
describe john brown as a terrorist
because this was an act of political
violence done to send a message done to
people the john brown had no particular
gripe against him they hadn't threatened
john down's life or anything like that
so this is john brennan he has decided
that slavery is so evil that it can
justify even murder
so john brown discovers well that
doesn't exactly save kansas the the
battle goes on
and john brown was a little bit
frustrated because he
didn't get the kind of response he
wanted i should add something here
john brown became semi-famous as a
result of this and he was also wanted
for murder in kansas territory so you
might think that john brown well he's
going to be arrested and tried or
something like that but in fact this was
in the days before
photography at least before convenient
photography and so there were no
photographs of john brown circulating so
the and i should also add there was no
federal law enforcement agency nothing
like the fbi to chase john brown around
so there were written descriptions of
john brown
but the the federal government because
it's the feds who govern kansas
territory they have to rely on local law
enforcement to apprehend him and all the
local sheriffs in various parts of the
country
had to go on was a written description
of john brown
oh and john brown could grow his hair
out cut his beard and vice versa and
change his name and so he could very
easily blend into the population there's
something else going on here too and
that is it gets back to this question of
the states versus the national
government
there were a lot of people in the north
including northern sheriffs who had
really resented the fact that they had
were being required to do what they
consider to be the dirty work of the
slaveholders
who
could very easily turn the blind eye to
john brown and okay they heard john
brown's in their county well that he'll
be somebody else's problem if we just
let him go because he's going in the
next county so john brown circulated in
the north and he circulated among the
abolitionist community as far east as
boston and he mostly was raising money
he was raising money for his new project
and his new project was an attack on
harper's ferry harper's very virginia in
those days west virginia now why
harper's ferry because there was a
federal arsenal there and john brown's
idea was to
seize the weapons in the arsenal and
distribute them among slaves in the
vicinity of harpers ferry and the slaves
would use these weapons to rise up
against their masters killing their
masters if necessary to achieve their
freedom and this would so shake the
institution of slavery that
slaves would lose their value and
eventually the slaveholders would have
to concede okay we have to give up this
institution so this is john brennan
and
he's trying to start a war to free the
slaves
it turns out to be a fiasco and without
getting into the details he is captured
he's arrested he's tried he is hanged
and in going to the gallows he slips out
a note to his jailer in which he
prophesies
that the evils of this country will be
purged only by blood
well
this sent shockwaves as you can imagine
through the south you know his attack
was on virginia he was convicted of
treason against the commonwealth of
virginia as well as murder and some
people who were killed in the raid
and so southerners began to think oh my
gosh if
people like john brown are running
around we are not safe in the union
so
this is oh and then what made it worse
was that people in the north those
northern abolitionists they hailed john
brown as a martyr
upon his execution and when southerners
started this said oh my gosh not only do
we have this murder run we have people
in the north who are praising who are
canonizing this terrorist this murderer
and it was not outlandish for
southerners to think southern
slaveholders to think if they remained
in the union first of all their
institution of slavery would be in
jeopardy and possibly their own lives
would be in jeopardy if there are more
people like john brown who were giving
guns to the slaves who would kill them
in their beds so
this is the situation in the south
but it's not the entire situation in
north in fact abraham lincoln is
watching all of this and he shakes his
head he shudders when he hears of john
brown because abraham lincoln looked at
slavery and said this is evil this must
be undone
but it must be undone lawfully it must
be undone under the constitution
lincoln as i say conceded nothing to
john brown in his belief that slavery
was evil but lincoln believed that in
the short run actions of people like
john brown would make the situation of
slaves worse i should point out that
john brown's raid on harper's ferry
freed not a single slave in fact john
brown was far less successful than
harriet tubman in freeing slaves john
brennan wants to start the war the war
doesn't start and further no slaves take
up his offer to rise up against their
masters because they realize this is
probably a suicide mission
so lincoln thinks first of all that
people like john brown and actions like
the raid on harpers ferry were bad for
the slaves in the short run but they're
bad for the slaves in the long run too
because they would cause southerners
to basically to to circle the wagons and
to resist any idea any arguments that it
might be in their own self-interest in
slavery now this was lincoln's hope this
this was what lincoln held out
lincoln believed that slavery would end
when southern slave holders concluded
that it was no longer in their interest
to maintain slavery now you might think
many people at the time thought oh boy
you know this is a long shot but lincoln
could point to the states of the north
who at one time had allowed slavery and
they changed their minds because lincoln
did believe
that
economies modernized and what a modern
economy needed was a flexible workforce
and slavery is
not flexible at all it's just the
opposite so anyway this is lincoln's
hope but it but it's something he has to
believe because lincoln
puts great faith he has reverence for
the constitution and he knew that the
constitution guaranteed slavery
lincoln's interpretation of the
constitution 70 years of
yeah 70 years by this time of
interpretation of the constitution had
concluded that the states
could have slavery as long as they
wanted lincoln's position basically was
congress can't tell the states that they
can't have slavery and that if virginia
if georgia south carolina if mississippi
wants to have slavery till kingdom come
those states can have slavery till
kingdom come
or
until the constitution is amended that
was lincoln's idea now he wouldn't have
to get unanimity among the slave states
but he would have to get some support so
this is what lincoln is aiming for
there's another thing about this that
lincoln is trying to revive his
political career
and he
he can read the demographic
charts he can read the census returns
and he realizes that the arithmetic of
the electoral college
pretty much guarantees that if this new
political party the republicans which he
has joined essentially a charter member
of the republican party if
they can nominate
uh
a moderate candidate a candidate who's
who's not does not scare people
then they will win they're just that
many more electoral votes in the north
and the republicans don't have to get
any electoral votes from the south the
republican candidate doesn't have to get
any votes from the senate
so lincoln is trying to sort of tamp
down any idea that republicans are
extremists and when he heard about the
raid on harper's ferry and this guy john
brown he's often called ossowatomy brown
after a battle it was fought in kansas
territory where he played a starring
role
that brown was not a republican and that
he lincoln was not an abolitionist and
he basically
put as much distance as he could between
himself and john brown as i say for the
reason that he thought that brown's work
was not only
morally
well problematic to put it mildly
murdering people in cold blood this is
not something that lincoln was willing
to endorse but also it was politically
counterproductive
so
lincoln sort of treads this narrow path
he's a moderate on the subject of
slavery he's opposed to slavery but what
that means for lincoln is slavery shall
not expand into the western territories
so he campaigns against stephen douglas
for
illinois senate seat in 1858 he loses
that election he really didn't expect to
win douglas was a sort of the lion of
the senate but what lincoln did was to
make a name for himself nationally he
was lincoln was running for president in
1858 when he was running for the senate
and in fact his name
spread around the country and he was
seen by the republicans by the sort of
professional republicans to be the safe
candidate he got the nomination in 1860
and lincoln was right the
uh arithmetic director of college meant
that he's gonna win and he did he won
the presidency
and at that point well at that point the
plot thickens um we know the story and
so lincoln gets elected and south
carolina leads a parade of southern
states out of the union
and you know we sort of we think we know
what was going on here
and um and you know for the most part
the general perception is true that the
south is concerned about the future of
slavery and therefore southern states
decide to leave and the issue is slavery
and yeah that's part of the story but
states like south carolina had contended
well in fact
the north some northern states as well
at times looking back to that i thought
i talked about the the two flaws in the
constitution you know what's the what's
the boundary between the federal
government and state governments and
this was one that remained unclear
and states would assert their rights and
the federal government asserted its
rights and and nobody had come up with a
solution
and there was a
strong school of southern thought but i
should add that daniel webster daniel
webster subscribed to this at an early
stage of his career that the states had
formed the national government therefore
the states could opt out of the national
government
and so
every
southern state that seceded did so
claiming that it was their right as a
state to do so
and south carolina had just about left
the union in 1833
1832 and 1833 over a tax issue they
didn't like a revenue a tariff
and they had claimed the right to do so
and so they left the union on the issue
of states rights
now the state's right that was of
greatest importance to them as most of
the ordinance's succession indicated was
slavery but there's something weird
about this because the president of the
united states has just been elected and
what he's saying is that south carolina
virginia you can keep slavery as long as
you want the constitution guarantees it
well
leave the union and the constitution of
the united states doesn't guarantee you
anything at all
and if you just think about the way
things turned out
if
slaveholders in the south wanted to
preserve slavery and they seceded for
that purpose
they sure did a terrible job because
within
two years of secession two and a half
years of secession slavery was on its
way out and by 1865 it was gone
if the southern states that the slave
states had not seceded
they could have had slavery until 1870
1880 until maybe well basically when
they wanted to give it up so anyway
lincoln has to decide what to do about
southern secession
and he makes very clear that south will
not be allowed to secede
but he also makes very clear that his
complaint with the south has nothing to
do about slavery it has everything to do
with states rights in particular he
rejects
the southern contention that the states
have a right to leave the union so
lincoln makes very clear that this war
is not about slavery he has to make this
point because first of all he's said all
along that the federal government
doesn't have control over slavery in the
states and the southern states can keep
slaves as long as they want
but secondly
not all
not all the slave states seceded
and maryland did not succeed and
kentucky missouri delaware did not
secede
and if lincoln declared war on slavery
then he would effect be declaring war on
those border states which were
absolutely crucial strategically to the
preservation of the union if maryland
had seceded the united states government
would have had to evacuate washington
and you know we'd be on the run so
lincoln has to say
that this war is about states rights
it's about the way you put it the war is
about the union these states don't have
the right to leave
and more than a year into the war oris
greely the abolitionist editor
you know i said mr lincoln you know
you've got to realize that this is
really the war caused by slavery and
naked said well he understood that
slavery was at the bottom of this
particular dispute but
lincoln said that you know this my war
is not about slavery says you know if i
could
at my voice to save the union if i could
save the union by freeing all the slaves
i'd do that if i could save the union by
free none of the slaves i do that if i
could save the union by freeing half of
them keep the other half in bondage i'd
do that my job is to save the unit
eventually eventually lincoln was
persuaded that saving the union required
freeing the slaves or at least freeing
the slaves of the rebel slave holders
because as generals pointed out and
people like frederick douglass argued
very strongly that slave labor was a
major war resource of the south
take that
resource away
promise freedom to the slaves
and entice
southern slaves to flee the plantations
and come to the union side and all of a
sudden
things change the balance so lincoln
issues the emancipation proclamation but
he
immediately said you know
this is a stop gap what we need to do is
to amend the constitution so
lincoln you know as the sort of the last
act of his life he didn't realize the
last act of his life but he gets the
13th amendment through congress and it's
fairly smooth sailing to ratification so
i'm going to stop there because it's
time for questions well thank you bill
that was wonderful that was a wonderful
talk we got a lot of great questions
that came in during your remarks and the
first one has to do with john brown's
family were there strong anti-slavery
sentiments among other members of his
family for instance his father
john brown's family john brown was quite
a family man he had 20 children by two
wives
and the children
the the children they didn't quite know
what to make of their father they all
grew up opposed to slavery uh given john
brown's powerful personality
uh it could hardly be otherwise and of
course
they lived in an abolitionist community
where this is what they heard and being
northerners of course they had no
material interest in slavery so with
that kind of education they would all be
opposed to slavery but some were more
opposed to slavery than others so he had
i can't remember exactly how many male
children but not all of them joined him
basically on the battlefront so the
older boys did
he had a daughter his several daughters
and one of his daughters married a guy
who was initially kind of taken by john
brown and joined john brown in kansas
but then when this son-in-law
sees
the lengths to which john brown is going
to go he basically says okay enough he
says i gotta go back and tend to my
family and he goes back to new york
where the extended family was living and
he doesn't come back john brown implores
him to come back said no no i'm not
coming back and he made up excuses uh
john brown's sons had a really sort of
ambivalent relationship with their
father they couldn't decide whether he
was the most impressive person that they
had ever met
or this kind of emotionally morally
abusive son
one of his sons said that his uh their
father um sort of looked like a bird of
prey and he thought that this bird of
prey was going to come down and get them
if they didn't do what he wanted them to
do
so
uh but interestingly enough john brown
was very tender
toward the younger children uh the older
the boys especially he expected him to
take up arms and join his anti-slavery
army but the younger children he was
tender toward and he was as tender as
could be toward his wives
even well i'm not there's no
contradiction here but they were the
ones especially his second wife who had
to tend the homestead while he was off
waging war against slavery and his
family at home lived on the kindness of
abolitionist strangers so there was a
subscription taken up to support john
brown's family so he could go off and
wage his fight and there's an
interesting dynamic that goes on among
the
the philanthropic abolitionists if one
wants to be a little bit less charitable
one could say the armchair abolitionists
who are funding john brown because he
impressed them enormously because he had
the courage of their convictions he
would actually do what they
wanted to do maybe thought they ought to
do but couldn't bring themselves to do
and it's
important i think that
they knew the stories of this guy who
had committed murder in kansas
but they
conspicuously declined to ask
john brown did you do that captain brown
they always called did you do that they
didn't ask him
and he made a point of not saying so he
had this air of mystery around him and
they well in fact when
when john brown was arrested at harpers
ferry
and he just was interrogated
oh and some of his personal possessions
were seized and it was published that he
had a bunch of letters
that had been taken so these people who
had been writing him letters they fled
the country he said we got to get out of
here because we might be
rounded up and hauled to virginia and
tried for treason against virginia too
right how about his parents do we know
how his parents thought about slavery
as far as i can tell his parents were
opposed to slavery but they were of an
older generation where the issue of
slavery seemed to be much less immediate
and and that's sort of the story of john
brown and why the 1850s is this time
when everything comes to a head because
it looks like finally a decision is
going to have to be made things are
going in the wrong direction on slavery
from the point of view the
the opponents of slavery in the days of
john brown's parents
slavery the the the general issue of
slavery things seem to be going in the
right direction
so
um there isn't that much known about his
parents beyond that
okay
now one of my favorite historical
documentaries is the american experience
one about john brown
um and one of our one of the issues in
that film has to do with whether or not
he was crazy and we got a question from
mel moore which asks says
you call brown a zealot in the title of
your book did he become a madman
if by madman somebody means that he lost
touch with reality and he couldn't tell
what was actually going on in the world
he couldn't tell reality from his
imagination no john brown never fell
into that category now john brown
did
fall in to call it the trance of the
person who realizes he's going to be a
martyr
and this is something that i'm really
intrigued when i try to get inside
john's brown's head and i can read his
letters from jail in west in virginia
and you can read his statements and
comments of people who talk to him at
the time
there comes a point when john brown
entered harper's ferry on the night of
the raid
he was fully convinced that he was more
valuable to the freedom movement alive
than dead
but between the time that he is captured
and the time he has executed he realized
that he's of greater value to the
movement dead than alive and so he makes
very clear
that he will not countenance nor
cooperate with any effort to free him
from jail and some of the people who had
rode with him in kansas were thinking
seriously of
going to
harpers ferry charlestown was where he
was jailed um and springing him you know
they thought well how hard can this be
it's just a country jail in fact it
would have been pretty hard because the
governor of virginia and then the
government of the united states just
surrounded the place with militia and
eventually federal soldiers
but he didn't want anything of it
because he realized that well he was
going to his maker
and he was going to his maker suffering
what amounted to in his mind
martyrdom for
this just cause
and
and this was this was what so moved
people like henry thoreau and ralph
waldo emerson that this guy would give
his life for a cause that at least so
far they had only been writing for and
speaking for so this was the power of
john brown's
example and it's you know it's a a
powerful statement you know you can't
make a more powerful statement than that
and this is of course the reason that
john brown has resonated throughout
history down till now
yeah i think of the line from the
melville poem the portent that calls him
meteor of war and that union soldiers go
marching off to fight to the tune of
john brown's body that's an inspiring
song for them so if you want to
ask yourself what was john brown's
contribution to history
you have to be prepared to answer
a corollary question but the corollary
question is actually a bigger question
than john brown
do you think
that the civil war or something very
much like it was necessary to end
slavery in the american south and if
your answer is yes
then like melville you'd say john brown
is the meteor that signals that the war
is about to start it's you know the
opening
shot of the civil war but if you believe
that then you will say that okay john
brown was simply joining the battle
ahead of when the battle formally
started
and you're going to applaud john brown
you know soldier who goes into battle
gives his life
on the other hand if you think as
lincoln thought
that a war was not necessary
then you take a rather different view of
john brown because john brown was a
cold-blooded murderer
and he was someone who tried to start a
war private citizen who tried to start a
war
and if john brown's actions contributed
to that war then there's additional
blood that john brown has on his hands
lincoln himself couldn't quite decide i
say before the war lincoln was convinced
that slavery would end without a war
by the end of the war in lincoln's
second inaugural address he's talking
about how it may be god's will that
every drop of blood drawn by the
slaver's lash
shall be paid for with a drop of blood
drawn by the sword lincoln's taking the
position and he's sort of from an
emotional perspective he pretty much has
to take this position
otherwise my god you know i'm
responsible more than anybody else for
the deaths of hundreds of thousands of
people and nobody could bear that
lincoln became much more religiously
inclined at least he talks and thinks a
lot more about religion during the war
it's almost as though he has no choice
but i'm just going to put one thing to
the listeners and that is that
slavery was very common in the world in
1800 essentially every country in the
world allowed slavery in 1800 in 1900
almost no countries in the world allowed
slavery
a couple iran
but it was only in the united states
that the ending of slavery required this
great civil war i have to make a partial
exception for haiti which actually
started its revolution a bit earlier
than that but you get the point yeah and
so
there doesn't seem to be anything in
sort of the history of
the world of freedom of evolving
attitudes that says you have to have a
civil war to do it and so if the civil
war could have been avoided then as i
say
it puts john brennan in a very different
light
that's great um we've gotten a lot of
questions about ethan hawk and the good
lord byrd now i haven't seen the film
have you and if you have can you speak
to
how it depicts him
i have not seen it partly because i
don't have showtime but also because i
make a point
of not mixing my fiction with my fact
and when i am writing about a subject i
avoid reading any fictional accounts of
the subject so i didn't read the james
mcbride book the good lord that the
series is space on when it came out
precisely because i know mcbride's a a
good author and he can spin a convincing
story and i could just imagine that i
would read something about john brown in
there and it would stick in my head and
i would think oh i read that in some
biography of john brown so i make a
point of not doing this
i've
read reviews
and
i gather that john brown appears on the
series to to have one or two screws
mildly loose he he doesn't seem like
someone who is is all there again i get
this only from reviews but that's that's
all i can say about the depiction but i
will reiterate what i said before that
john brown
uh certainly could tell reality from
illusion so
if anybody makes a claim and i'm not
saying that the series does the john
brown was this crazy man
then i think they're wrong i should add
the republicans uh like abraham lincoln
they were the first to say john brown
was this crazy man because they didn't
want to be blamed for john brown the
republicans lincoln had trouble already
he was always called a black republican
and black republican reflected both
their black hearts ascribed to these
republicans and the fact that they seem
to be um they favored rights for the
black people in america and so you know
lincoln would not go anywhere near an
abolition any abolitionists but let
alone any violent abolitionist
yeah i think of lincoln in the cooper
union address where he's addressing
southerners and he says you try to make
us out to be john brown's
that's not who we are as a party right
and it's but well so there's a great
irony here
and that is that john brown tries to
start a war to free the slaves and fails
he doesn't start the war he doesn't free
any slaves lincoln tries to avoid the
war and when he does go towards not to
free the slaves to save the union but
lincoln's war is the much bigger war and
it does end by freeing the slaves so if
there's a lesson here it's that history
is full of ironies and what you start
is not necessarily where you end up
yeah that's right and you know connected
to that one thing i just thought of when
lincoln meets with frederick douglass in
1864
can you talk about that for a second or
no for my literary purposes if frederick
douglass had not existed i would have
had to invent it yeah because i tell the
parallel and intertwining stories of
john brown and abraham lincoln but the
two never met
and so i needed somebody not only who
had met both who would tie those parts
of the story together but also because i
could tell the story of john brown i
could get inside john brown's head he
writes his letters and
you know i get that i get same with
lincoln but i need to know what they
look like to people on the outside and
it would be great if i had the same
person looking at both of them because
i'm doing in effect this comparison and
frederick douglass knew john brown he
met john brown in the 1840s and so he
sort of knew what john brown was up to
and the kind of things that john brown
hoped to accomplish
he eventually met abraham lincoln and
well actually there's a striking moment
in the story the story in my story where
john brown tries to talk frederick
douglass into joining the raid on
harper's ferry right and frederick says
no no no basically what frederick
douglass says is i'm a writer not a
fighter but in addition
he knew that john brown's
raid his mission was going to fail
because frederick douglass had been a
slave and he knew that slaves were going
to weigh their chances of coming out of
this alive and they would realize no
they're not very good
and so
frederick douglass was less out there on
the subject of abolition than john brown
but he was farther out there than
abraham lincoln and so
uh frederick douglass tries to slow john
brown down and he tries to speed abraham
lincoln up right until during the first
part of the war frederick douglass in
his newspaper named the douglas journal
he is berating abraham lincoln for being
so slow this is a war about slavery you
have to declare war on the slave rules
you have to do this and he just thinks
that lincoln's going so slow so slow
until finally the emancipation
proclamation and then he finally says
okay lincoln you know you finally got
right on this
and lincoln brings douglas into the
white house he considers him a confidant
and invites lincoln to the reception of
his second inaugural and so and and
douglas again as i say from literary
standpoint
i needed something like this douglas has
the last word in my book because he
talks about the significance of both
john brown and abraham lincoln and he
concludes in essence that they were both
necessary in their own individual ways
to the cause of emancipation
yeah well thank you so much bill we are
out of time that was a wonderful talk i
know our audience really appreciated it
you can get bill's book the zealot in
the emancipator from the gettysburg
heritage center at
gettysburgmuseumstore.com and bill has
pre-signed these book plates and so
please order from there and you can get
your own copy signed by bill thank you
again this has been a wonderful talk
thank you i love the opportunity
while photographs of earlier conflicts
exist the civil war was the first to be
extensively documented through this then
nascent medium
next debra willis